what do you call it kid with no arms and
an eyepatch names when did my mother
first subscribe case next to me good
question I was 8 years old I was 8 years
old
she brought me into the dining room she
sat right across the table from me she
said you know your father and I love
each other I said of course you and Dad
loved each other
more than two people in the world could
possibly love each other
she said well two men can love each
other in the exact same way that your
father and I love each other
she said what happens when two men love
each other like that
what they do is they they take off all
their clothes they get into bed and they
[ __ ] on the Bible
hey guys like impressions like
impressions hmm why Socrates [ __ ] [ __ ]
I [ __ ] [ __ ] let's get [ __ ] when I
[ __ ] [ __ ] Noah fans and or BOTS I [ __ ]
[ __ ] I cluck [ __ ] nice girls are nice
for no good for nut sucking they'll need
a serene night to green-light a
[ __ ] but that' bees he was slaves
the old [ __ ] [ __ ] booed the nice
girls praise be to sloth [ __ ] I have
a list a list yes the list of all the
[ __ ] like master I've never [ __ ] or
sucked these [ __ ] and thus my nuts are
[ __ ] pissed so when I [ __ ] the lucky
[ __ ] my nut removes her from the list
another dumb [ __ ] bucket struck from my
nut sucking suck at [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
bucket list yes you hear the influences
Chaucer jeez pages are blank I know it
why am i lying to you [ __ ] can be white
black brown Pinker Amin they can be
skinny with big tits or beats skinny
with small ones
[ __ ] can be perky prep your posh with
their brains in their clothes all shrunk
from the wash excuse me what other [ __ ]
are pretty and funny and smart these
[ __ ] can lift on your thoughts when
your dick to your heart they can talk
about science music or art they can put
you together or they can pull you apart
but don't trust these [ __ ] don't don't
you dare the force you trust them and
love them and care and then they'll be
gone and then you'll be aware of that
hole in your heart that that dumb [ __ ]
left there thank you very much
my aunt used to say slow and steady wins
the race
she died in a fire
I moved to UM Hollywood recently from
Boston where I grew up and places and I
I I heard about these sort of wild
Hollywood party nights that people would
have and I think they were true until I
moved to Hollywood and I started having
them anyway this is a there's a song
about a crazy night that happened a
couple weeks ago it's called what did i
do last night
[Music]
hey hey one in our last night
[Music]
cried myself to sleep those in glass
houses shouldn't throw stones or
macerate the day time for my people
still living in the streets still living
in poverty I want to tell you I'm doing
this for you my success is your success
I know they may be thinking hey if you
really believe that why don't you use
some of your money to help rebuild the
neighborhood instead of putting spinning
rims on a gold jetski and to that I say
uh-oh course is coming every single day
doing everything away they go ladies say
oh boy anymore
you got a few like a tuna I'll smell you
later I met a fat chick and I [ __ ] her
in an elevator it was wrong on so many
levels
[Music]
fifteen cents a day you can feed an
African they eat pennies he shouldn't be
able to talk before him yeah yeah III
got a fair point I am I'm of the the
younger generation so I just wonder for
all of you who are you yes do you have a
legacy or something now what about what
if I gave you like a scenario could you
just do it could you do like a little
version of that yeah like let's pretend
that we're all bank robbers robbing a
bank you're in charge and we're gonna
put put the gun up to the clerk and say
give me your money go for that wait I
think Bono if you want to help poor
people sell your tinted shades you
two'll I said we went to the abortion
clinic just the other day and we were
really hungry so he had to say feed us
feed us
penis penis penis I'll take my medium
rare my dog's stomach was very upset so
I put him in the car and we went to the
vet and on our way to the vet I killed a
cat he is in that ironic
I adopted a child from overseas to
rescue him from child labor factories
and on his very first birthday we went
to build-a-bear works
[Music]
it's a man I are oh and I see Ino rir oh
and I see yes in a water park is burnt
to the ground and a tow truck has broken
down I always used to cry when I laughed
and then I was raped by a clown I was
watching Al Gore on CNN he was talking
about the environment and then out of
boredom my pet polar bear shot himself
[Music]
I dated an animal rights activist one
day she got really pissed because I was
eating veal that was wrapped in pita
bread pita it isn't that iro and I say
yes anaheim us stand-up comic and I
always sit and slouch and I got my
girlfriend pregnant on my sterile
uncle's pull-out couch
ironic iro and I see yes in a Bob Barker
got all of my pets pregnant
the grandfather had Alzheimer's and one
day we were
[Applause]